مساء الخير مش ممكن نفهم كثير مما يجري
على الساحه الدوليه
من غير نفهم اللي بيحصل في المحيط الهندي
اللي تحول واحد من اهم مساحات الصراع
خصوصا بين ثلاث دول كبرى هي الصين والهند
والولايات المتحده
الاجابه علشان نفهم ايه الفيدراليه المحيط
الهندي بياخذ اهميه المتزايده ان احنا
نشوف خريطه المحيط الهندي ولما نشوف خريطه
المحيط الهندي ان اكتشف ببساطه ان هذا
المحيط وهو ثالث اكبر محيط في العالم يربط
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا بمنطقه شرق
اسيا يعني لو تصير على الخريطه هل اي من
جنوب الجزيره العربيه عمان واليمن وبعدين
بيتجه جنوبا عشان يضمن جهوده والشواطئ
طبعا جهودا الصومال وكينيا
وزامبيا وموزنبيق وجزر
عشان يشمل الباكستان
وطبعا القاره الهنديه
الهضبه الايرانيه وبين تجارب شبه القاره
الهنديه حتى وصولا الى اندونيسيا ومدخل
المحيط الهادي ومدير
يعني باختصار شديد جدا هذا المحيط يربط
الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا حيث منابع البترول
والمواد الخام المختلفه دول شرق اسيا اما
اذا اقتصاديه يعني ايضا باختصار اكثر هو
يربط ما بين مضخه العالم للبترول ومن
اهمها ومنها يتم العالم بالمواد الخام
المختلفه بمصنع العالم في شرق اسيا
المحدده ما كانشي اهميه كبيره بل سنوات
الحرب البارده
طوال سنوات
البارده من سنه سبعه واربعين الى سقوط
الاتحاد السوفيتي سنه واحد وتسعين كان
مركز الثقل الاقتصادي موجود في الغرب
الولايات المتحده واوروبا بالدرجه الاولى
وبالتالي كانت كل السفن التجاريه وناقلات
البترول متجه من المنطقه الى الغرب تغير
الوضع في السنوات الاخيره وبدا مركز الثقل
الاقتصادي انتقل من الغرب الى الشرق في
عدد كبير من الاقتصادات
فيتنام والفلبين وطبعا الاقتصادات الاكبر
في اليابان ومؤخرا
مركز الثقل الاعظم في الصين ثم الهند
وباقي دول شرق اسيا طيب ترتب على هذه
النقطه الاقتصاديه احتياج متزايد لم يكن
معهودا لل بطول والمواد الخام والبترول
والمادي الخام موجوده في الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا وعلشان هذه المواد تعبر الى دول
شرق اسيا لابد انها تعبر عبر المحيط
الهندي او ممرات وما هو الخليج العربي
وبحر العرب وخليج عدن والبحر الاحمر هي
ممرات متفرعه من المحيط الهندي
لازم هات عبر ممرات المحيط او من فروع
المحيط الهندي ثم المحيط الهندي نفسه
وصولا الى الهند والصين الهندي ولم طبعا
باعتبارها اكبر دوله وتطل على المحيط
الهندي ثم الى المحيط الهادي حيث تقع بها
كل الدول الاقتصاديه العظمى في الصين وفي
اليابان
الاقتصادات
الجيده فيتنام والفلبين وكوريا الجنوبيه
الى كده احنا ما يعني ما بدنا
الجديد في القصه انه يكون هذه الدول تحتاج
بترول البطوله انتقل عبر المحيط الهندي
الجديد في المساله البريد في المساله انه
مع زياده الحاجه الى البطوله
وبالتالي والمواد الخام
ذهابا الى دول شرق اسيا ثم يقول الاساطيل
التجاريه الضخمه التي تتحمل انت لهذه
الدول الى اسواق العالم كله زاد احتياج
هذه الدول لتامين اساس لها التجاريه سواء
اللي بتحمل البترول او اللي بتحمل بضائع
ان وبدات المساله بالصين اللي بدات تسعى
لتامين هذه الصادرات والواردات الهامه جدا
بالنسبه لها ونفهم المساله على هذا النحو
بدون بترول وطاقه بدون طاقه يعني بصفه
عامه لا يوجد اي نشاط
وتحديدا البترول والغاز تاتي من الشرق
الاوسط والتعليم الافريقيه ولازم
تسعين في المائه منها اقلها عبر اه عن
طريق البحث عن طريق المحيط الهندي وصولا
الى هذه الدول طيب مشكله الصينيين مشكله
الصين انه بسبب هذا الاعتماد المتزايد جدا
على الطاقه هي في حاجه انها تؤمن مرور هذه
الطاقه عبر المحيط الهندي بس هي لا تطل
على المحيط الهندي وليس لها ولم يكن لها
اسطولا وجود يذكر عسكريا في المحيط الهندي
والمحيط الهندي بيسيطر عليه ب يعني بدرجه
كامله من الولايات المتحده منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه والى الان يعني بعد خروج
بريطانيا من المعادله
اكبر اسطول موجود في المحيط الهندي هو
للهند باعتبارها اكبر دوله
هي موجوده علاقه الصين بالولايات المتحده
علاقه تنافس وعلاقه غير وجوده وعلاقه
الصين والهند علاقه مازومه من عشرات
السنوات ان لم يكن من السنوات وممكن
للتكلم على ازمات لا تنتهي بين العملاقين
الاسيويين الكبيرين خلافات على كل الصعد
خلافات حدوديه و مائيه في جبال الهملايا
وفي منطقه التيبت وفي منطقه كاشمير وفي
حربه منهم سنه اثنين وستين انتهت بهزيمه
الهند وما زالت عالقه في اذهان الهنود
وتكرر العلاقه ما بين البلدين وفيه خلافات
حدوديه قائمه في اكثر من نقطه على انجرار
ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه كيلو اللي بتربط
البلدين حدود مشتركه وعندهم ازمات خلافات
دوليه على العلاقه من باكستان وعلى
العلاقه بدوله بد ان يعني كثير طيب
وبالتالي هي تشعر انا منها
الاقتصادي تحت رحمه الولايات المتحده
القوى العظمى الاساسيه في المحيط الهندي
وجارتها الى جوده الهند علشان تتخلص او
تقلل او تؤمن مصالحه بدات انهى تزيد من
وجودها مش بس في مو في المحيط الهندي ولكن
في منطقه المحيط الهندي ومناطق اخرى طرق
بديله للمحيط الهندي
تشوفيها بتعمليه في المحيط الهندي لو شفت
انت بالاساس
المبادره او المشروع العملاق الحزام
والطريق هو في الحقيقه جانب اساسي منه
ايجاد طرق بديله للطرق البحريه تحديدا
المحيط الهندي الذي تسيطر عليه الولايات
المتحده و خاضع للنفوس الجندي دوله الهند
بتعمل ايه بتعمل عده امور منها انهى بتزيد
بشكل بدات اليوم اسطولها بالقدرات
العسكريه في المحيط الهندي طيب تم بشكل
عسكري تام كمان بتزيد من نفوذها ومن
وجودها في قول الدول الموجوده الواقعه على
المحيط الهندي من خلال اقامه موانع
التجاريه
وتواجد كثير اقتصادي في الاول وبعدين
ياكلوا او من المتوقع ان يتلو وجود عسكري
بتحاول تزود تخرج بالمحيط الهندي والتي
طرق بديله تحصل فيها على المواد الخام
والبترول بعيدا على المفيد الهندي تماما
من خلال طرق بديله زي اه يقول الطرق
والمشروعات الضخمه اللي بتعملها في اسيا
الوسطى في اسيا الوسطى تخيل كده بس على
الخريطه تلاقي عندك الهند الصين وروسيا
وفي بينهم منطقه اللي هي منطقه الثانيه
لكل السبع الدول اذا انتهى بكلمه
السيستاني على ارض يعني اه اوزباكستان
يعني اه ارض الاوزبك منطقه ال
السبع الدول دول اللي هي تمثل سته منهم
منطقه اسيا الوسطى بعد باكستان وبغض النظر
عن التقسيم الجغرافي السابع بول سبع دول
دول اللي هما بكلمه ست ان دول الصين ناشطه
جدا انها تعمل فيهم مشروعات تجاريه الهدف
انها تنتهي في النهايه بانها توصلها
بالخليج العربي وبحر العرب وبالتالي بعدها
المباشر الى البترول الخليج وبترول الشرق
الاوسط بعيدا او من خلال ممر بديل عن
الملاحه في المحيط اللي
ذكره مشروع الممر الاقتصادي اللي موجود في
الصين اللي ممكن كل اللي موجود في باكستان
ولا ممكن نتكلم عليه في وقت لاحق اللي
بينتهي بميناء كوادر اه اللي كل الناس
طبعا سمعت عنه في السنوات الاخيره الهدف
من ان ينقل بترول العرب البحر المنطقه
الشرق الاوسط الى الصين عن طريق بري بعيدا
عن المحيط الهندي ا بعيدا عن الولايات
المتحده والهند وفي نفس الوقت لكل البضائع
الصينيه الى المحيط العربي او الخليج
العربي وبالتالي الى باقي دول العالم
فكره الصين انهى تلتف على النفوذ الامريكي
والنفوذ الهندي من حلم طرق بديله لكن
القصه دي بسبب كابوس بالنسبه للدولتين
نتكلم على الهند الاول الهندي تشعر انه
يتم محاصرتها بدوله عدو من كل الاتجاهات
سواء داخل المحيط الهندي يعني في المنطقه
اللي بتعتبرها
فيها وهو التعبير اللي ترفض الصين او في
منطقه اسيا الوسطى المنطقه اللي بتمثل
دولار في الشمال ان تكون مثلا عشان
الامثله كثيره جدا اذا اخذنا مثلا ب امثله
داخل المحيط الهندي واحنا تكلمنا مره في
ال على حلقت اسرع لانك انت لانك متابعه في
اقل منطقه اقل منطقه بينها وبين الهند
حوالي اربعين كيلومتر يعني يعني تقريبا
ملاصقه الهند وكانت منطقه نفوذ هندي فوجئت
الهند والصين وتقيم مشروعات عملاقه
وتستحوذ عمليا على اكثر من ميناء في
سيريلانكا كانت هي ت ما بيقدر بان هي هبطت
الى سيريلانكا وسارعت بالقاء كلمات قالها
في مشروعات اقتصاديه ومحاوله الحصول على
اكبر مساحه ممكن تستغلها تكريم عسكريا في
سيريلانكا حتى لا تترك المجال الصينيين
على ابواب لو اتجهنا بمثال برد وتكلمنا
عليه قبل كده
الموجوده في المحيط الهندي واللي تكلمنا
عليها كل الجهود ي الصين
اول قاعده عسكريه هناك لنفس الغرض اللي
انا بتكلم حضرتكم عليه تامين مصالحها
في هذه المنطقه المتزايده الاهميه من حيث
الموارد الهندي جاءت ايضا ولكن استغلت
تعاقدت مع اليابان وهي عدو وخصم للصين
متفق تستغل قاعدتها العسكريه هناك وهي
اكيد بنحو لتسعه لاقامه مناطق العسكريه
القواعد العسكريه في دول اخرى اذا تكلمنا
عن الخليج العربي مجرد ان الصين الصين
طبعا بتقوى علاقتها بشكل مضطرد معقول لدول
الخليج الهند ايضا بتسعى بنفس السابق اقل
شويه لانها طبعا ال اقل بكثير في الاقتصاد
من الصين لكن سعد ان هي تعمل اتفاقات
تجاريه واقتصاديه مع دوله ال طبعا بدعم و
مباركه امريكيه مع اكثر من دوله على راسها
سلطنه عمان اللي فتحت لها عدد من الموانع
ب اتفاق تجاري مع الهند يقابل ميناء قويدر
الصيني اعط وقت ميناء
رقم اذا كنت بنصح
لما الصين لما الهندي شايفه انه الصين
ميناء كوادر هي كمان تعاقدت مع ايران
لتطوير معينه
اللي موجود فايران لنفس الهدف انها توصل
عن طريق بري وبضائعها الى منطقه الخليج
العربي
ويصل ها البترول عن طريق الاسف بحر العرب
والخليج العربي فايران ثم وسط اسيا ثم
يصلها في كل ما كان فيه الصين
بت في ايضا الهند الصراع ده في دول اللي
احنا نتابع اخبار هادول كبيره
او للدول الصغيره زي مضيف مثلا
ما تذكر
كل الممرات المائيه المهمه الى الهند
والصين ب يسعون للسيطره عليها من مره
المادي كلنا نعرفه
موزمبيق
مضيق ملقا ال كل دوله من الدول دي بتحاول
ان هي تسيطر عليه اكبر قدر ممكن من
الوسائل والقرار بالفعل الولايات المتحده
من الصراع هناك الولايات المتحده تعتبر
المنطقه المحيط الهندي والمحيط الهادي
منطقه واحده وعندها قياده عسكريه واحده
للاشراف على المحيطين عندها الحقيقه طبعا
لانه المحيط الهادي اسف المحيط الهندي
بيرتبط في بحر الصين الجنوبي عن طريق مضيق
ملقا وبحر الصين الجنوبي
هو جزء من المحيط الهادي طيب هي عندها
قناعه من عشرات السنوات ال اتترك ابدا هذه
المنطقه من العالم لاي دوله او لاي تحالف
منفرد
وقناعتها اذا هي الضعف قبضتها على هذه
المياه معناها بتتخلى عن عرش او صداره او
لزعامه العالم وهي اياها زي بريطانيا اللي
تحولت من بريطانيا العظمى الى بريطانيا
فقط
يصفونها الحربيه مياه المحيط الهادي
والمحيط الهندي
وعندها ايمان ايضا بانه ما يمنع الصين من
ازاحه امريكا على عرش العالم هو ان ما زال
طبعا اكثر من سبب من بينها سبب اساسي جدا
هو انه كل خطوط امداد الطاقه التي تصل الى
ال الى الصين هي واقعه تحت رحمه الامريكان
وسط لها في المحيط الهادي والمحيط
الهندي وفي اللحظه الا تضع في الوجود
الامريكي في هذه المياه وتامل الصين تماما
على مصادرها من الطاقه من الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا وغيرهم الصين لن تتردد عن فرض
سيطرتها بالكامل على بحر الصين الجنوبي
اللي احنا نتكلم نعم
وحسم صراع الحدودي مع اليابان في بحر
الصين الشرقي والسيطره على الدوله المارقه
عليها اللي هي طيوان بدعم من الولايات
المتحده وتصبح سيد العالم بلا منازع
يعني احنا قدام منطقه هي لها تحدد موازين
القوى بشكل الصراع في القرن الواحد وعشرين
اشكركم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]